now just choose this is my reason to add
in one more piece of notation which is
not really another piece but I've seen
how you kind of I don't know about you
you might be getting sick of writing C's
okay they're everywhere and they kind of
just clog up what you're writing so
there is another way to write this
which just retains the important parts
the numbers okay
but it does look a bit weird the first
time you see it okay so I'm gonna write
it just about so you can see what I mean
instead of writing and see ah we write
it in a set of brackets like this the
important numbers at the end of the up
they don't be important um you know C's
not a number okay so I read this as six
C 0 and 6 C 1 and 6 C 2 bit quicker to
write and it is clear because there
aren't so many letters flying around so
it does uh on the basis of this I could
for instance right out Pascal's triangle
completely using this notation okay for
instance the top row P is what what
number row is at the top one it's the
zero with row right so it's zero to zero
and then the next row down your row is
once everyone true 0 1 choose one and
then it's going to be 2 2 0 2 choose 1 2
choose 2 and then 3 0 3 1 3 2 no 3 yeah
I just haven't gone far enough
okay now that's interesting things you
can see when you start to write things
like this for instance one of the
properties that I did not name but you
can almost kind of see yeah right is how
is Pascal's triangle formed how is it
formed the first time you learned at it
you just format by addition don't you
right
so for instance you can see here that
I'll just pick out of anyone about this
guy to see 0 plus 2 C 1 should be equal
to this guy right I sort of go in like
that yes 3 so you want that's how I get
that number right I add up the two ones
above me I make
they become so this would be one plus
two equals three that's what's actually
equal to now that's one particular case
but how do I state that in general terms
there's a couple of different ways to
say this okay for instance if I say all
right and shoot ah I'm in the eighth row
I pick the earth turn what's the next
one over one yes I have to go down a row
which means I'm not in wrote in anymore
I'm in row n plus one we turn am I after
it'll be the UH plus it's gonna this
number matches here doesn't it you see a
path so it's gonna be the R plus 1 term
and you can generalize that this entire
Danny is so important it goes in here
it'll be number four it's called
surprisingly Pascal's identity okay
because it's it shows this okay it's
from that structure